they're saying Finland
is the happiest country in the world can
you believe this Finland
where children don't get shot
is the happiest [__] or maybe they do I
don't think they do but the Finnish are
the happiest people in the world happier
than the United States of America this
is what they're saying this is their
this is the New York Times it has been
ranked the happiest Nation on Earth for
six consecutive years
but in this article they talk to the
individual Finns who are
I don't know
they're not exuberant
they're satisfied
they're like relaxed they go yeah we're
cool
and I read this article we're going to
bring up some interesting
parts of it I don't know again I've I'm
not shocked that America's doesn't rank
because again I've you know talked about
you know the idea that I very few people
seem happy in America even happiness in
America seems to be a frenetic kind of
manic behavior that's not like a Nordic
satisfied and relaxed person it's like a
Matic junkie whose dealer is just called
the back that is happiness in America
it's like somebody very very excited to
tell you how good something's going for
them uh but it's not like that calm cool
collected
deep satisfaction that maybe the Finish
have
so here in the article on March 20th
United Nations sustainable development
Solutions Network release its annual
World happiness report what a
interesting thing which raids well-being
in countries around the world for the
sixth year in a row Finland was ranked
at the very top they keep winning
they always win
but when they interview them
individually they go I wouldn't say that
I consider us very happy he said Nina
Hanson 58 a high school English teacher
from a mid-sized City on finland's West
Coast I'm a little suspicious of that
word actually which I I am too Nina
they spoke to about a dozen Finns a
Zimbabwean immigrant a folk metal
violinist a former Olympian and a
retired Dairy Farmer
about what supposedly makes Finland so
happy
are subjects raged in a in age from 13
to 88 and represented a variety of
genders sexual orientations ethnic
backgrounds and professions to get a
full picture of how happy Finnish people
are
um they came from colacola as well as
the capital Helsinki turku a city on the
southwestern coast and three villages in
southern eastern and western Finland and
I read the article and what it comes
down to is they like nature they like
welfare and they're satisfied with very
little
which is good but that's how you get
happy right they enjoy nature they
actually enjoy it like Americans don't
really enjoy nature unless we're
destroying it or we're using it for our
own game
um nature in America for the most part
is kind of been ruined like we do have
Yellowstone we have some beautiful
national parks but most nature is just
you know it's hanging on by a thread
it's the fires are always burning down
there's droughts everywhere the Lakes
aren't at a high level so nature in
America takes a back seat you know there
are people that go out and do things in
nature but a lot of times that's murder
or rape I mean it's not oh you know
there's regular there's people that go
out and don't kill in the natural
environment but it's not our main thing
like our main thing is not the nature
like we have some pretty nature but our
main thing is like the cities the vibe
the clubs the drugs the money the cars
that you know and in Finland they like a
tree
like they like seeing green grass we
take nature and and put it on the
outside like we take fake moss and put
it on the outside of buildings or we
take trees and rip them out of the
ground and put them inside of a hotel
lobby we dominate nature which I think
is good like we don't let nature we're
not going to be Nature's [__] you know
like there's a lake in uh Austin called
Lake Travis which is heinous it's a
heinous like it's a man-made lake and
it's uh it looks like it's in a crater
like an asteroid hit the earth and
there's a crater and it's blue because
it's Limestone on the bottom it gives it
that nice color and they buy water from
Lake Mead and they buy water from
Colorado and they direct it via the dam
into this Lake Travis which is a heinous
Lake kind of I mean when you look at it
and and the drought has made the lake so
that the lake is not even full it's kind
of like
you know it's like the levels of the
lake aren't aren't good
so people go out and they go on boats
and they get hammered and they drink and
there's a place called Hippie Hollow
where they get naked and everybody's
like screaming and yelling and you know
I'm not this is a fun summer activity
but it's not really about the lake right
like it's not about it's just about like
we've created this big slip and slide
for adults to just you know to take part
in like it's about us it's not about the
lake we don't really give a [__] about
the lake we care about our ability to
use the lake to get drunk to use drugs
to dry fast on boats and have fun water
sports but that's what America views uh
nature it's like it's like an impediment
to our having a good time it's like we
you know the lake uh last year the lake
levels were low people didn't care
they're like [__] it it's just hey this
is uh the lakes are [__]
and it's a heinous like not a nice Lake
it's not a naturally occurring it's a
man-made lake we make Lakes
and we put some fish in them and we go
go out there and do it go out there and
get drunk get on the boat do the and
there's nothing wrong with it you know
get on the the [__] jet skis
have fun but we make nature to please us
whereas The Finnish people the Finns go
to Nature and their depression is lifted
because they're in nature and I don't
know what they do out there in it but
apparently they like it they also have a
very strong social uh safety net well
they're saying they're a psychological
benefits of nature in Finland
that these people there's psychological
benefits of nature like they go to
Nature and they feel better about
themselves they also have a nice welfare
state so nobody's cast out of society
for not performing
um
so rather than happy they are more
likely to characterize Finns as quite
gloomy
a little Moody
and not given to unnecessary smiling so
they're just they're just these are
different types of people they're Nordic
um they're not they don't have that kind
of manic highs and lows
that Americans have
but they have sustainable lives like
their idea of success is being able to
meet basic needs that's the big
difference between those Nordic
countries and America they want like
basic needs a little house
a little fish
and a few potatoes a little family
and they and they have Art For Art's
Sake no one gives a [__] about what the
Finish do
they don't have a finished ice spice
they have just this for the sake of it
they have it for the sake of it like we
nothing in America is for the sake of it
nothing if you ain't trying to get big
it's not worth it in America nobody's
enjoying anything everybody in the back
of their head is thinking that whatever
the hell they're doing is going to lead
to something else the Finish don't
believe that so the Finish enjoy uh
music uh and entertainment but they
enjoy it for the sake of it as opposed
to Americans who are like trying to get
their kids on the line for American Idol
so the kids can get famous and they can
retire like Americans just are chasing
Fame and chasing money this is part of
our culture we want fame and we want
money we don't really care about nature
does it that does not do anything for us
we want fame and we want money and if
we're not famous and Rich we want our
kids to be famous and Rich
you know the fins don't feel like that
they want their kids to have a little
house a little fish and little potatoes
and that's fine with them that's a nice
way to live America
we want our kids
to be famous
first
and Rich
we want our kids to be big time
big time we want to tell people like
that's my kid we don't care if they have
face tattoos if they're on drugs we
don't care if their lives are ruined we
don't care if they're in debt to record
companies we don't care if Hollywood is
molesting them we don't care if they're
being exploited by everyone in their
lives we don't care if they're if
literally their manager and agent are
stopping them from killing themselves
and throwing them back out on stage none
of that matters to us as long as they
are famous and Rich that is fine
that is fine and then the next step if
they're not famous and rich is like good
job that you can tell people about a
decent house big house nice wife Nice
kids like look at that but first and
foremost we'd like them to be famous and
Rich and the Finns aren't doing this
their lives are not built on this
unsustainable Rat Race that Americans
are in Americans are constantly in this
rat race of being the best at everything
the most successful putting in the most
time getting the big job getting the
corner office getting the big house in
the pool and the cars but the Finnish
people but but again I don't know what's
better I don't know what's better
I don't know what's better
is it better to have a little house with
a little fish and a little potatoes
and you it's a tiny little house and no
one really speaks
I speak occasionally
or is it better to live in a mansion
where everybody in their rooms is
plotting against everybody else
and they're plotting to try to get their
lives where they want them to be I don't
know
I don't know what's better do you want
to live in a place where you get excited
by something as stupid and gay as nature
is that like
something that you want to be a part of
I mean it's easy to say that yes
Americans are sick and our value system
is wrong it is and you know everything
and our country's rotted it has
but
the flip side of it is like the Finns
have never had any impact
culturally on the world and you could
say well America's impact is now
negative well maybe I'd agree with you
but we've certainly done some good
things I mean name me a Finnish movie
you know or something in terms of music
I mean I don't know it's not as easy to
just say like hey
The Finisher the happiest people in the
world
and we should all take a page out of
their book I don't know I I don't know
if that's just easy to say it's people
believe like if people
really want to do that
so here's listen to this this is
interesting and this goes right to my
point Public Funding for education in
the Arts including individual artist
grants gives people like his wife Herta
a mixed media artist the freedom to
pursue their creative Passions
it also affects the kind of work that we
make because we don't have to think of
the commercial value of art said Mr
kisky
so a lot of what these artists make here
is very experimental listen Herta
sucks
and she's making a lot of crap
and the reality is the government's
funding that crap and there's nothing
wrong with that on its face
but the reality is it's not good
mixed media art is rarely good and
there's no way that this [__] is doing
anything good there's no way there's no
way that first of all I know some of the
biggest losers in the world if you were
to give them grants from the government
to make sure so that they didn't have to
work and they could just make art it
would not make the art good it wouldn't
it would relieve the financial burdens
on them but that wouldn't necessarily
make them valuable as artists
so I I I mean can we get some or hurt is
there anything that we can see here from
Herta the the Finish mixed media artist
because I want to be proven wrong but I
have a sneaky suspicion that it's a
waste of everybody's time it could be a
yeah Herta here it is hertagiski
now I could be wrong here but this is
what you get in a country with a social
safety net where people uh you know are
you know satisfied and I'm not so what
is this what am I even looking at what
is it I kind of like that this is called
after the end I kind of like that that's
not bad after the end what do you even
see here well it's like a picture of uh
it's I don't know but I it's not
horrible
well now go up there what is this with
the two what is that two eggs
oh boy
this is what you do when you don't have
to think of the commercial value of Art
and everybody's satisfied
to just loaf around and eat a little
fish and little potatoes
what else what other masterpieces
what is that a torture chamber
I think it's like uh yeah I mean again
you know
are you trading this
are you trading Tina Turner or Elvis or
or biggie for this for Herta
let's be honest these are the questions
we have to ask ourselves
is that what we want do we want a
society
where we don't have Run DMC but we have
this where this [__] took scrunchies
and put them on a metal pipe and he's
calling his car and that's what the
government pays for the government pays
for this [__] to put scrunchies on a
metal pipe and call it art and that's
what they pay for you know what I think
would make her better working a Taco
Bell for minimum wage
and then fighting her way out of that
sorry Herta